here's hoping a reality star will be
born and new bachelor Colton Underwood
here's a look at Colton and the 30
ladies vying for his heart on the et's
learns he met with with Colton who want
you to know he's in it to win it I feel
like I'm all-in
I want to find a way I could tell you
that the first thing the 26 year old
former football player wants you to know
is that he doesn't take himself too
seriously and I mean just check out
those dance moves
going through the Bachelorette and going
through bachelor in paradise brought me
into a lot of serious situations but
there's also another side of me that
sort of this fun-loving loose full of
energy and I can't wait to just you know
be myself still based on history and
this sneak peak of Colton season we know
the man tears will be flowing and he's
cool with it
every time I put myself out there good
you know everybody says I cried I feel
like I've only cried twice so far but
you know what I'm fine with that
I'm comfortable with that something else
Colton is comfortable with his virginity
being a hot topic I am a virgin but
that's just a small part of who I am -
faith is what's gonna happen with
fantasy suites Colton how are you going
to approach that tell me what you're
thinking we're gonna cross that bridge
when we get there I'm waiting first to
be madly in love with somebody so if
that happens by the time fantasy suites
comes around so be it actually good
sport because take a look at this promo
poster he's Steve Carell from the 40
year old virgin
it is fantastic I want to say this I
attended an event that Colton was at and
boy did he get a lot of attention from
the ladies I mean a lot
[Music]